hello everyone and welcome to a truly
spectacular chess puzzle I found a while
scrolling Twitter yesterday and I know
most of you guys are not on Twitter so
uh it would be a shame for you guys to
miss this one it's uh it's uh I don't
show uh puzzles often on this channel
but when I do yeah you can be sure it's
uh it's a nice one so it's white to win
uh however you can there's only one way
to actually win it's not an easy
position as you can see uh black is
threatening Checkmate if you move the
queen then the bishop Queen combo just
Queen to B2 Checkmate so what can you do
here how can white win this uh you know
uh give it a give it a few seconds or
you know uh well uh how much time you
can invest that's up to you but you will
be very very happy when you spot this
one I solved it uh you know in a matter
of seconds but there is a very you know
uh
there's a certain reason for this so I
have added uh what why it's the play and
win
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on uh spotting the
correct idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is of
course Pawn to B4 it's a really weird
move to play in a situation like this
but uh if you consider what your options
are then the move definitely comes to
mind like I said if you move the queen
it doesn't really matter where then just
Queen the beat to his Checkmate also you
cannot give Queen to f8 uh Rook to f8 to
Checkmate as the queen is covering that
square so there's really not all that
much to try and if you try Rook captures
on G7 which I'm sure some of you tried
uh then of course uh black will not
capture the queen and allow you this
very nice Checkmate but rather just
capture the rook and now after Queen
captures on G7 uh black is still up a
full piece just let's say B6 uh black is
up a full night so of course you can't
play this however after this B4 move you
have achieved everything you need to
achieve you have not moved your queen so
black cannot deliver Checkmate and also
the queen no longer guards the f8 square
so now if black doesn't nothing Rook f8
will be Checkmate so what are what are
Black's options here there really aren't
any you could play something like Bishop
to E7 although it's a very weird move to
play but it does prevent Checkmate df8
square is covered but now uh the queen
can just be captured Queen captures an
A3 and of course now white is completely
winning so what is your option after
this um B4 move other than Bishop to E7
uh you could also play Queen capture Sun
B4 this makes sense but now uh the
problem is white happily trades Queens
Queen captures on B4 and now after the
Knight captures now Rook to f8 will once
again be Checkmate Bishop to d8 Rook
capture 78 and that's uh that's pretty
much it that's the solution to the
entire puzzle just Pawn to B4 and also
one of the reasons why in every game
where you guys always laugh about it you
guys think it's some sort of a meme or a
running joke or whatever when I
mentioned the B4 move but B4 uh is an
incredibly powerful move and it very
often wins the aim for white so in every
position even in a weird one such as
this one do check it if it's possible to
play it it just might be the only
winning idea yeah for a very very
particular situation such as this one uh
so yeah that's the game or rather the
puzzle hope you guys enjoyed it I used
the Mr hoodie guy and excellent
subscriber for this one as I was
representing the hudiga and you guys
were representing the excellent
subscribers so hopefully uh all of you
were able to spot that b for idea I know
I was extremely happy when I uh founded
but that's why I said I solved this
pretty pretty quickly because that's of
course the first move that I always
check in any position
uh so yeah I really hope you enjoyed it
do share it with everyone uh so they can
enjoy it as well impress someone you
know in the bar or or in the library
yeah you never know what might come of
it uh so and once again hope you guys
enjoyed a bit of a shorter video for
today but we've had some intense chess
over the past uh over the past two weeks
so I hope you guys don't mind uh I would
like to thank Antoine Shukla Henry
Spraggins Mr Robert de crayon uh saurav
medrata and the Michael ovens for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
and thank you for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day